اشد مراره من قهوتها هي ذكريات ميساء التي
تعرضت لاعتداء حين كانت قاصره الا ان
الاكثر مراره في رايها ان المرتكب لم
يحاكم بسبب دعم سياسي حضي به وفق قولها
مرت 13 عاما على الاعتداء وما زالت ميساء
تبحث عن العداله انا لولا الصغر وحده ارجع
انبش فيها القضيه وارجع اخذ حقه ما بتراجع
ولا لساني لانه يمكن مش بس هذا انا صرت
اتطلع فيه بعض هلا صار حقي وحق كل البنات
قله من النساء اخترنا البوحه بتفاصيل
تجاربهم فكانت ساحه البرلمان ميدانا
لعشرات الشهادات
اما اغلبيه النساء فيحجمن عن التبليغ عن
الاعتداءات وفق احصائيات الجمعيات
الحقوقيه احجام تعود جذوره الى اسباب
ثقافيه ترتبط بالوصفه الاجتماعيه فضلا عن
قانون طرفه المنظمات اشحافا في حق الضحايا
لما بيكون في
تعاطي مع الجرم بجديه يعني هي عقوبه مشدده
على اكيد هي بترضع لاكتار هذا الجرم وبتحس
النساء اكثر على التبليغ وخلف هذه الاسوار
محاولات النيه لتعديل قوانين تقع حقوق
النساء ونظم حمايتهم في صلبها ورغم تبني
البرلمان قانونا يجري الاعتداءات على
النساء فان المعضله تكمن في المقاربه
المجتمعيه لهذه القضايا هناك بعض المواد
في قانون العقوبات يا اللي يجب اعاده
النظر في التشديد العقوبات الغاء بعض
المواد تعديل بعض مواد ولكن هيدا بيحتاج
ايضا ليس فقط الى تشريع التشريع يحتاج بما
يخص المجتمع ايضا الى رافعه اجتماعيه
ثقافيه والى تبني ووعي من قبل المراه ومن
قبل المجتمع قد تشكل التعديلات القانونيه
مدخلا لتوفير الحمايه للنساء الا ان
الوعيه يبقى رافدا اساسيا لضمان تطبيق هذه
التشريعات
لطالما كان الموروث الاجتماعي اقوى من
القوانين خصوصا في القضايا التي تمس
النساء واقع عم قام ماسي ناجيه من
الاعتداءات وفاقمها غياب شبكه امان توفر
الحمايه للضحك وتكفل معاقبه الجنات كارمن
جوده الجزيره بيروت